over the last decade what we've been
doing is trying to build tools to let us
watch and control the operation of the
brain if we can understand the brain the
way that we understand computers for
example maybe we could understand the
brain of such a level of detail that you
could really comprehend how it generates
things like thoughts and feelings
actions and sensations for example one
technology that we've developed is
called optogenetics but not to genetics
we install a gene that encodes for a
light-sensitive protein and a cell or
set of cells in the brain and then we
can aim white at those cells down an
optical fiber or with a scanning laser
so then you can play back activity to
the brain people have put artificial
sensations into the brain can you figure
out how a smell is represented for
example people can trigger emotions and
some groups have done some pretty
philosophically interesting experiments
so for example a group at Caltech has
activated certain clusters of cells deep
deep in the brains of mice and if it's
the right cluster you can actually
trigger a mouse to become aggressive or
violent they'll attack whatever is next
to them even if it's like a rubber glove
right you can also study diseases you
can for example turn off overactive
cells in a seizure and you can actually
shut down seizures in animal models of
epilepsy these technologies are mostly
being used in animals to reveal how
brain circuits might be changed for a
therapeutic benefit so for example my
group collaborated with another group to
figure out that certain brain patterns
actually might help clean up the debris
in Alzheimer's disease from that
knowledge you can then go and develop
other non-invasive strategies to try to
help prevent reduce the effects of or
reverse brain disorders however if some
people are exploring whether
optogenetics might someday be used in
humans directly in one area that's of
great interest is blindness millions of
people cannot see because the
photoreceptors in their eyes the light
capturing cells have died off if you
could convert the rest of the eye into a
camera though by installing the off the
genetic tools in spared cells of the eye
maybe you could help these people see
again an energon ology we've developed
allows us to map the structure of the
brain the brain is really dense and
complicated in a cubic millimeter of
your brain you have around a hundred
thousand cells called neurons and
they're wired up they're connected at
junctions called synapses and they're
about a billion synapses in that cubic
millimeter so mapping how the brain is
wired up is a truly daunting task
how can you image such a complex 3d
structure with the nanoscale precision
required to knock the wiring well we do
it through a fairly unconventional way
in contrast to the last 300 years of
imaging where you use a lens to magnify
light coming from a sample we actually
take pieces of brain and fuse them with
a chemical that's a lot like the stuff
in baby diapers and then we add water
the baby diaper material swells and
blows up the brain to make it a hundred
times or a thousand times or even more
bigger by volume
so because we move all the molecules
away from each other in a smooth even
fashion we can map their relative
organization my hope is if we can map
out the key geometry of the brain and
how molecules are organized maybe we
could simulate a brain circuit while
it's doing something like constructing a
decision or sensing something or
performing an action it's not a very
good metaphor but imagine of the brain
you're trying to solve the brain in the
same way that you might solve a computer
you need to control the computer that's
the keyboard we use off the genetics you
need a map of the computer the wiring
that's what we're using expansion across
before and you need to watch the
computer in action the monitor and we're
still working on those technologies
currently I hope we'll have that solved
in the next couple of years but if you
can put those three things together the
wiring the watching and the control you
can do a lot of interrogation of how
computational circuits work
[Music]